[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation we are
here for what if Episode 7 a
surprisingly great season of Television
joined once again by Koy jandro who I
gave five real reject shirts to and he
decided to wear none of them today I was
wondering would this come up in the
first inro or the second were you
wondering you know what happened I hung
them all up cuz I liked them cuz I
wanted them to like get really nice yeah
but then I GL they're in the closet you
know what it's Christmas week Christmas
week what do you think of this episode
is it good we don't know what it is
we're about to find out in real time so
you know what to do leave a like um also
be sure to subscribe click the
notification get notified when our
reaction for seven no eight is up on the
yeah eight is up on the channel and
thank you to prepper for being awesome
and helping us Ed down these highlights
and thank you to everyone specifically
you who has joined us at our patreon
page becomeing super sexy rejects over
there you get the full inter and watch
along reing up with your own copy of
what if and John and I cover several
things over there exclusively with
highlights and watch Longs included
let's get to it people let's do
it in a campaign of Fire and Blood King
Odin sought to unite the nine Realms
under the Throne of Asgard still can't
get over how good this looks it's so
much better okay get over I can't even
place what differences but it's gorgeous
his executioner and firstborn daughter
Hela oh we're going to get a Hela
episode nice one by one the branches of
the world's tree fell under their
control they should have kept hell
around is it capelan Chet that would be
nice the entire Cosmos is out there
waiting to be ruled you wish to stop at
nine rounds there comes a point in time
my dear when a warrior must lay down his
sword that's definitely Anthony Hopkins
yeah
unist who else can sound like
that unable to quench his daughter's
thirst for blood and imprisoned her in
hell oh it's cool we're actually just
seeing what happened in this universe
hel's insolence inspired another idea
you see father without a fight I'm no
one
woo oh reversal of Fortune no God should
have dominion over death who has so
little appreciation for life well
ridden I now take from you your power oh
interesting reversal yeah Thor one with
Hela Thor one and Ragnarok yeah
oh is hel banished to Earth no no I cast
you out whosoever wears this Crown
should she know Mercy shall possess the
power of Hela oh definitely Hopkins oh
yeah this doesn't look like New
Mexico Oh is she going to the 10 Rings
is this going to be what is this the
place called come come on remember the
name chongi land Chicago or we just saw
an Asian guy in New Mexico yeah he just
lives
there
no oh there this when we get the the 10
rings that fueled his power Shu and woo
knew all too well the most powerful
forces on Earth often come from Beyond
Amen to that brother that's an
interesting concept Hela wiwoo the weird
benefit that we have of of being
fortunate enough to watch this in
advance is not knowing what every not
knowing the title of the episodes yeah
it's really fun to have like it feels
like roulette we're like let's see what
today is O idra Saba's back I feel like
they underused idba the whole time they
had him I'm shocked he comes back cuz
he's so great hey man he needs the money
cuz he was underused that's true idra is
hurting you know he's not out there yeah
him and jimon Hanson never get underused
black actors the miracle of nature that
brings the sky down to earth so poetic
but when woo was about to discover
someone far more intriguing had fallen
from the heavens I love how that helmet
felt perfect yeah that's where it goes
cool oh man Hips Don't
Lie midgard
wonderful oh she speaks Mandarin I'm
afraid the only one who gives orders
around these
parts is me
I do appreciate a man who's brave enough
to attempt uh
jewelry but you see darling I'm not most
people I'm the goddess of
death oh she can't do the thing she
can't do it just no powers take her oh
dear here we
go hella oh no oh that's really funny
mortal PL o
revolting I'm just a helpless
[Music]
woman oh she's still SK she can still
fight she has the skill yeah it would be
hard to learn how to fight in real time
without getting injured though oh like
even punching would hurt for her he
[Music]
attracted that power it is not of this
realm nor are you
I was not expecting shanok if I only had
my crown it would be you who would kneel
before me then show me what a
fascinating Dynamic I can't de if you're
brave or stupid done your crown and we
shall find out he just wants to
challenge it's really lodged in there
isn't
it how does Gra work here on me you know
what doesn't matter how does gravity
work father please don't do this to me
I'm embarrassed
[Music]
father it's also fun mirroring at the
rain and everything in the first Thor
yeah but setting it here with W wo
watching over just give it's a
completely different Dynamic that I am
very much appealed to because he would
be drawn to someone like her immediately
what is this an invitation I like white
girls if you would join me for dinner I
also like a young wio getting some time
to shine I guess I've been subjected to
worse forms of torture color's not bad
at least your blood won't stain it when
I slit your
throat he's so attracted are they going
to fall in love Brides even wear it on
their wedding day wedding day I didn't
realize you meant to make my
imprisonment a life
sentence I see in you a fighter hella my
father once saw the same that fight he
nurtured it exploited it and then as
soon as my ambition outgrew his own he
called me a monster when woo can do the
same yep familiar Story the 10 Rings
were a gift bestowed upon me a gift I
give back to the world in return by
taking command of its
people our world is plagued by dangerous
forces is that what you take me for just
another dangerous
Force oh man your father may have feared
the fight in you but I do not fight with
me hel and together we can protect the
world protect the world interest well
that's how he perceives it I just know
what I want and what is
it is she just playing him
yeah
yeah I don't know she might actually end
up falling for him too sweet
dream I want her
[Laughter]
alive it's back to feeling like the
animatrix yeah I was going to say it's
pretty especially the color composition
very animatrix I love when these
episodes have been embracing
genre oh that's right he's
back well you saying you know a way to
get out of here oh I'm sorry is that
your sorry I was under the impression I
was talking to your
[Music]
face I think the characterization is so
well drawn no pun
intended I guess you're not the first
ass I've ever followed into
battle Yeah we didn't get a lot of her
but I did feel like she established who
she was pretty quickly and I wanted more
so it's nice but at this Joy Ride of
yours doesn't bear fruit it will be your
ass for your face what a great way to
justify gway with the word ass Disney
rebellious heading towards
[Music]
Deadpool I bu to buide the thousand
years of war to die at the hands of
foliage this clever there's like a she's
like Kathleen Turner like that kind of
that Middle Middle Atlantic accent p
forward I'm sorry you want me to tr you
after you've led me into the enchanted
murder
Forest her being just offut by being
mortal is great like a
swashbuckling Leading Lady quality to
her did you hear
[Music]
that show yourself I command
[Laughter]
you
o oh my
gosh oh cool
hello she is falling from my view why
didn't Marvel promote this at all this
is so well done like one of their best
pH I don't understand this is so well
done with a crazy cast our realm is a
border protecting the people of Earth
from threats of the underworld why mean
no harm my quarrels with a man named wwo
technically with my father say it was
both of them also my dad has this new
girlfriend friger she's dreadful woman
not really a fan of hers either so yeah
it's just those
three one cannot fend off Darkness with
more Darkness only light yes it's a
lovely sentiment to be
sure the meme stripping her away from
her powers really gets you to know her
and I am the goddess of death and what
better way to secure your mission than
by recruiting me to your cause the whole
fending off Darkness with with like
things the manipulation being so on Our
Sleeve is
great cannot be serious fear not we have
methods to ensure she won't betray
us it's all coming back into play I
really don't know how this is going to
end I don't either and I love the
blending of magic our new magic and our
magic we've known 10 rings that could
even destroy a God if such power indeed
exists on midgard there's no telling
what its people could be capable of and
our age of Peace might be shortlived oh
this is so compelling they're they've
really achieved making these shorts
stories feel like oh this could be a
great feature they all feel like movies
yeah they're cinematic and we can expect
to get to the fighting when but our
practice requires a cultivation of your
inner World a Unity of technique and
spirit oh good what fun what about those
fire knives just breathe hel it's like
those classic M movies I grew up on
where white person stumbles into white
Foreigner stumbles into like Asian and
learn yeah this was a common Trope four
years infinite possibility in the
blankest of
canvases Focus Unity
peace why do you seek to master our
practice to overthrow wed for what so I
can take his 10 rings for myself and use
them to seek Vengeance on my father or
what but why and when all the Realms
across the cosmos have finally been
conquered
cool it's like hypnosis
enough oh my God sweet young Hela in her
child
work father why did you chain him he is
born with the heart of a fighter the
king must tame his threats to ensure
that they fight is that fenis yeah
yeah wow we really humanizing her
freedom freedom from control the freedom
to choose my own path that's what that's
what it all really comes down to now
you're ready to
begin what's cool is that even though
the plot isn't Canon Tor main timeline
the humanization of her would still be
consistent this will still enhance Hela
if we see her again yeah that's what
liked about the Iron Man story is it
didn't take away from the loss but we
enhanced him the breath in your
lungs when your mind is at peace you can
see the lesson oh this is awesome not
bad you still have a lot to
learn please turn Hela into a white
savior the goddess of death white savior
to live the
lessons then you become a
master
[Music]
well hell has become a martial arts
master that's so cool but is she worthy
if you choose this path you will walk it
alone no my father chose a path for me
long ago and if I ever wish to be free
to choose my own and I must face him
with or without you it's cool because
when Shan Chi came to this part of the
land he had a training montage or
whatever but I actually feel like
there's true development for Hela here
yeah like Shan was kind of rushed is
ironic considering the desperate run
times yeah pull back pull back behind
the
Gates
wow these two Magics fighting each
other impressive armor make some Dragon
SC and VI with the strength to combat
threats of Untold mystical power
personally I missed the dress
though these two teaming up who would
have
coming in as the villain oh the body's
desending in the backg end slow motion
embrace me daughter I have come far to
avenge your name Avengers embrace me
daughter return to my side hel and we
shall bring midgard under our protection
truly
no I will no longer be party to your
Conquest perhaps you have forgotten I
stripped you of your crown without it
you are nothing oh I love the we get to
see the villainous side of Odin yeah we
need to separate him from G who's G that
is oh he even going to see his weapon in
action I love that the dragon armor is
useful in this exact capacity it's
great well talk about wish fulfillment
Darkness cannot fend off Darkness only
light can
the T Rings look so
[Music]
cool I knew I should have locked you
away but I had the
chance just amazing choreography and
camera work I wonder if it was MOA
especially the martial
artist yeah you show the martial art
skills oh grab
it so much happening oh
damn cool
[Music]
sacrifice yourself wo fire
KN the prophecy everything she
wanted fire dager
ass oh sweet
cool
[Music]
ten ring punch it plays like when you're
fighting Odin in a video game and then
it ends with a cut scene on the final
100% yeah like they just cut to that for
us let us end this violence once and for
all oh that's how she's Worthy is
[Music]
forgiveness Odin you son of a my
daughter pass and a chance to end her
life just like you said no God should
have dominion over death who has so
little appreciation for life she never
forgot the
words oh and then Odin's own doing just
like it always
is but learning the lesson literally at
the hands of Odin oh my God and reag
yeah I was thinking it should come back
as a different color yeah she's hell of
the white yeah
[Music]
pure Majestic God look at the lines the
throne is yours if that is indeed what
you seek only from there can I unmake
your Empire the nine Realms will know
freedom and the cosmos soon thereafter
she has the Loki AR basically in 30
minutes on an ancient Battlefield a man
and a woman a moral and a goddess the 10
rings and the armies of Asgard forged an
alliance both Loki and her just need to
realize why they are the way they are
and they'll realize they're actually all
right people little inner child work
changes a lot an Empire not of
conquerors but of
liberators liberators cool campaign
Across the Universe which forever prove
even the darkest of Hearts can come to
no peace
wow
that's amazing that last shot doing the
slow-mo and also Gathering the energy of
that Ragnarok like slow-mo that was so
cool I just I love how they really do
ask I I really get this sense that this
time around the writers thought to
themselves truly the question of what if
what would happen if Hela interacted
with Wen wo in this time period and went
through this experience and then they
from a psychological standpoint and let
that dictate how the plot would unfold
and who is Odin at this point in time
who's W wo at this point in time how do
we want Hela to end like where do we
want Hela to find herself also like what
movies didn't get the time to flash out
certain characters because I've always
felt like Ragnarok didn't give hella her
do so it feels like they were like what
can we do to blend these things and I'll
also say the the outfit that she
was wearing was so gorgeous I feel like
a change clothes if Ki had taken the
clothes out of his closet the clothes
available at reation shop.com I could
Ascend where you get clothes like this
RR shirt to represent yourself as a
citizen of the reject Nation or our
awesome child protection services shirt
with Joel from The Last of Us carrying
baby grou or space babies space babies
of the Galaxy or any of our Ahsoka
shirts or a recently launched Doctor Who
shirt one of our top sellers this year
the one of the best ways my personal
favorite way to support the John because
we are creatively involved with them
ourselves people so please go ahead get
yourself a shirt say segue it's a
natural segue natural seg my delivery
remains sincere that's the key yeah
that's that's his
Arc yeah my AR to sincerity just just
boom look at him he found his sincere
pitch yes yes both vocally and in
delivery is a pun uh I do find myself
Eng engaging into the point where I'm
like oh yes we are doing a rea
we' just be silent because I find just
to be silent and absorb so want to
appreciate which to me is the mark of
breath work yeah it's the mark of any
good um any any good thing that we are
actually reacting to is when you're like
oh yeah it's that engaging um so yeah
please koi thoughts speak it into the
Universe I love a good uh wax on wax off
Walkabout story I'm a big I'm a sucker
for finding your inner peace
uh I'm a sucker for therapy and they
definitely had a lot of therapeutic
elements especially the inner child work
being the most obvious but I really love
when a character that you like becomes a
character you love and I have always
felt like Hela was underappreciated in
the in the pantheon of of the Rushmore
villains people always talk about they
always talk about uh you know kilmonger
and Thanos and you know I've always had
Hela in my uh top five Marvel villains
but she only had one movie and I didn't
feel like they ever got to really
establish more or a way she could come
back and this was the last thing I
expected but to give her that Loki Arc
to give both Odin his journey of
darkness which we've hinted at but not
really gone down and then to have winw
get time in his period all of this as a
mashup of everyone getting to play is
what what if Comics do really well and
you mix that with this animation making
it feel like it's accurate to a time
that we didn't get to experience as much
of uh this was so beautiful this was
really a great episode that really plays
with narrative in a fun way where you
mentioned these character growth arcs
she she did she she
literally she became White she got
whiter she she couldn't be she was so
white she hell a white got white past H
white got whiter and then saved uh but
she uncolonized but I I do feel like uh
when you have these narratives that you
had mentioned where you go back to the
character in their normal continuity
this will affect my experience of Hela
which is really exciting I like when
things like a what if comic can make me
go oh that is a a a direction of the
character I hadn't thought of but it
does affect my mainstream continuity so
this was uh one of those episodes where
I I really wish Marvel had doubled down
on how good this was cuz I didn't think
that was Kate Blanchett if you told me
Kate Blanchett came back to Hela as one
of the reasons to watch what if I would
have been way more excited yeah well she
has the the personality and the Cadence
in this episode of those charact like
it's a it's a genre blend of a couple of
of course can't think of any specific
movies right now I mean you were like
saying Karate Kid and like but there's
also those those other kind of fantasy
movies where like guy from modern day is
thrusted into period piece time you know
like espcially the 8S yeah those kind of
like comedies family comedies or
something there's like a lot of those
kinds of films it's a little bit of a
blend of that with with a bit of like
that romanting the stone aspect to it so
she has this hodg podge of personalities
and and I I loved I I I I'm I'm right
there with you I Echo all the same
sentiments that you had of um falling in
love with her character even more so and
then even getting a chance to see wwu's
romantic side which was teased in it but
it it was teasing shangqi but you get
more of his heartbroken melancholic side
and here you get to see him when he's
like at the prime of his Conquest days
yeah falling in love and uh where he's
such a charmer then and also getting to
see Odin at his villainous time where
he's also in the conquest at the time
and and the mash this feels like the
genuine wish fulfillment of what would
happen like that improv game of like
what would happen if this happened you
watch it come to life in a way where
you're like oh I crave seeing versions
of these guys come into live action
reality like like last season was just
strange Supreme I just want to see that
guy and then this is many this has been
delivering on so many and then this one
to give that um that that Asian genre
and martial arts blend and but also with
those other kind of swashbuckling films
that we sort of grew up on all mustered
into one with honoring the Fantastical
mythological elements and giving us
great action on top of that with a
wonderful Arc that does feel reflective
of Loki you know realiz your childhood
trauma you know you set realize what you
actually want not fulfilling your
father's goals of you yeah it's very
it's very much a Loki AR and now you're
the benevolent leader in all this and
and then once again Thanos about to get
his ass kicked always he's right there
waiting he's the punching bag you know
those guys are a punk Thanos is the
punching bag of the wh ifs I also think
that this is one of those really cool
things where in comics you have those
variant toys like when you've got a
different action figure because it's
dressed different like I immediately
thought like man a hell of the white toy
be awesome this is doing that comic book
thing where you've got variations on
characters that isn't just a variant in
the modern context of like it's a
different Universe this feels completely
like a new character while being true to
the character and they're nailing it man
this season's great the last thing I
expected to do at the end of this year
koi was be here with you and say what if
season 2 is genuinely better than most
comic book things that came out this
year wow you're right I mean all the DC
ones for sure peacemakers this year last
year Peacemaker was okay I'm just I'm
just gonna say Peacemaker is my favorite
DC show I'm just making sure I'm being
fair but this is up there with like gen
V for me and um invincible so far
uh Loki is my favorite but this it's
hard for me to quantify Invincible
season 2 cuz it's so short it's notet so
not
complete yeah it really is cuz I I
really loved a couple episodes but
there's only four so it's like but I do
agree this is one of the best comic book
adaptations of the year and I would
never after what if season one thought
I'd be uh it's better than Quantum Mania
secret invasion of Marvels by a lot yeah
it's like the only like out out of the
for me Loki is the best thing there's
Guardians 3 which is great
you but like across the spiderverse Loki
and this are my top three comfy I would
say this is part of the Great Camp of
combook things this year yeah and not
part of the Bad
Camp not part of the mid or bad and so
it D had four movies this year I know
and it blows my mind that this movie
that this show is I thought with this
lackluster promotion they were I was
like I thought they were burying It
Disney Disney knows they got another
stinker on their hand instead I'm like
guys what do you do this is the one you
should have had your yeah this is so the
premere had the creators which was cool
but it didn't have like anyone from the
cast that I heard know what the hell is
the S strikes over yeah and these cast
is huge like anyone what's going on
there was nothing at the LC cap like
this is such a big
event it's insane how good this is I
don't know man it's a disappointment
it's a disappointment of what is going
on with the lack of press my question is
what if they promoted it yeah see that
movie cuz this should be everywhere
there should be a bigger conversation I
the last thing I expected us to be here
would you being like I'm looking forward
to watching the next episode yeah yeah
so yesterday in our real time uh we
filmed a bunch and then we today like
our texting was totally different of
like okay wait we're actually going as
opposed to like well on we got to film
like this was a different Dynamic Al
together yeah no I'm here going there's
only two left I got to remember to like
express my thoughts yeah yeah this one
had me mesmerized this one and it also
had that meditative nature where was
like very tranquil and like the the the
that world always makes me like calm and
quiet and it worked cuz it was so
immersive and plus I love a good white
savior I mean look at me come on
obviously it's what we do I watched the
help
recently not for this channel no just on
your own yeah I did actually you don't
watch a lot of movies on your own you
watch the help that was the one I did on
my own how often do you watch a movie
you're like I'm going to watch the help
this is the move well I watched it
because other people were going to react
to
it yeah I needed a work okay so it's
still for work let's not let's not pret
I was gonna say if you casually watch
the help of all the time you sp I still
thought it was touching and boys it a
white savior film and the the caucacity
of those people they're not just white
they glow I I I loved it like man this
is what we need more of loveed it and I
know Viola Davis disowns it or something
I don't know she rejects it says one of
the bad career decisions she's made or
some like that I she like straight
up say something like I shouldn't have
made that movie oh wow
but I loved it and she's great she's
always great she's great in the movie
yeah yeah this this movie needed the pr
of the help God so guys what is your
favorite white savior leave it in the
comments below I think Midwestern Jesus
for me you know how how everybody paints
him like you and McGregor even though
he's brought in the Le too broad I was
thinking like a cinematic with like like
Tom Cruz and Last
Samurai that's a hell of a white savior
Matthew MCC in that Slavery movie he did
12 Years of Slave he wasn't in that was
he
no no the one that was true yeah you
know those guys that you mix
up Brad Pit was in 12 years slave yeah
he was produced it true help
save he did yeah Brad Pit was a white
savior of that while producing it to
show how good he is and making movies
that help people I mean in all fairness
in that time they would have got that
guy out of that situation is a white guy
and at that time the only thing that
would have got in that movie made is
Brad Pit money
look at him go white savior in
twice Neo he's like half asian is Neo
white savior he's half white half asian
he's does that count as white he
literally is a Jesus like parallel like
he's I thought white savior mainly
qualifies as like white person enters a
specific kind of culture or ethnicity
look all people save them from most
people or troubling the oppressed people
of Zion that mostly aren't
White that's true black man calls on you
Morpheus is like hey we need you to
learn Kung Fu and appropriate this
culture the other black people on my
Council are not a big fan of you or
really just one guy there's other white
people there's one white bad guy one
white good guy there's guy with the
eyebrows yeah but cyer bad guy and then
then uh you know Neo learns guess is a
wi saavor I guess so a little bit it's a
stretch it's a stretch I can't think of
any right now which is ironic cuz that's
like the biggest Tri true and it's made
by you know trans director so it gets a
pass sure sure sure sure sure but fight
club's written by a gay man so does that
allow you know I don't know if
Republicans when they say snow fake they
understand who they're quoting I've
always found that funny like when they
call people snowflakes I'm like you know
that's a a gay man trying to come to
terms with being gay and you're out
there espousing his film as this hyper
masculine like do you know what you're
saying they don't all right well I think
we made our Point did we do we have one
that's the question what if Greg
coy